there is something seriously interesting
going on over on hbo at real time with
bill maher obviously i've been spending
a lot of time talking about this that
bill maher represents a very
small faction
of liberals who remain true to
liberalism i at this point might have
some political disagreements with bill i
would say i've shifted away from that
sort of pure liberal position uh but i
do agree with him on a lot of things
and and what we agree on or disagree on
is actually irrelevant bill represents
what a sane liberal is which is why so
many conservatives are often saying hey
i disagree with bill maher but he's
right on free speech he's right on
mandates blah blah blah blah blah well
bill is really going all in on this and
he's really picking a fight with the
left and this is what we've needed all
along we have needed the good liberals
to step up i tried for five years to try
to get enough good liberals to step up
they kind of couldn't do it they're
afraid of their own shadow i think
there's reasons for that there are flaws
in liberalism in and of itself
but bill's doing it and credit is due
and i'm going to give the guys some
credit so this is a little portion uh
friday night on real time with bill
maher people sometimes say to me
you know you didn't you didn't used to
make fun of the left as much yeah
because they didn't give me so much to
work with
when
normal people read that san francisco
has basically legalized shoplifting
they think democrats have gone nuts
they think
you know that ted cruz cruz guy
seems like a real stiff
but at least he believes in the concept
of shopping with money
it's not
it's not my fault that the party of fdr
and jfk is turning into the party of lol
and wtf
[Applause]
members of congress
tweeting things like cancel rent
cancel mortgage and no more policing or
incarceration
declaring that capitalism is slavery
canceling lincoln and dr seuss teaching
children their oppressors and math is
racist making mr potato head
gender-neutral
and now an emoji for pregnant
men real i'm not making it up
yeah
you get it bill the problem that
you and i are having or let's say the
the difference of opinion or difference
of conclusion is that at the end you got
to stop voting for these people and at
the end the problem is that it has
infested the entire democratic party and
the problem is
that there aren't enough
good democrats old school jfk daniel
patrick moynihan ed koch old school
classical liberals left they are now i
would say the moderate part of the
conservative movement i would include
myself in that so you know he talks
about ted cruz there and it's like yes
he makes a little joke about ted cruz
but then in essence he's saying yeah ted
cruz says you have to you know pay for
stuff with money in essence meaning oh
ted cruz believes in the rule of law
believes in capitalism
believes that this thing that we're all
doing is pretty decent and that's better
than the democrats but
it's like
until you're willing to say i might vote
for someone like ted cruz then we still
have a problem now i want to give bill
more room by the way to to make that
adjustment right so it's like last week
we did the video where he was talking
about florida saying how great it is in
florida but then he said i'm not moving
to florida and it's like
bill
bill maybe you should move to florida
you live in los angeles which is a
[ __ ] run by these people who show up
to sofie stadium without masks while
they put everyone else in masks so so
that's a bit of a disconnect there it's
like what's at the end so bill went on
to talk about why the people on the
right like him so much lately
a few weeks ago fox news's dana perino a
former bush press secretary suggested
that the democrats should recruit me to
run for president which is kind of
special to see if bill maher is
recruited to run for
the presidency
let's get this straight it's not me
who's changed it's the left
who is now made up of a small contingent
who've gone mental and a large
contingent who refused to call them out
for it but i will that's why i'm a hero
at fox these days
[Applause]
which shows just how much liberals have
their head up their ass because if they
really thought about it they would have
made me a hero on their media
okay i think i'm a bit of an expert on
this as the y i left the left guy have
you seen the video it's on the youtube
and i wrote a whole book defending
classical liberalism
but there's a couple interesting things
here first off the fact that dana
perrino on fox news is saying you know
bill maher should run for president
shows you that conservatives actually
like disagreement with people in a sane
way like conservatives and i see this
all the time all the time
people come up to me on the street and
say what dave what happened to the old
school liberals we used to like arguing
about things okay so they were
pro-choice we were pro-life okay they
wanted more taxes we wanted less taxes
but what happened to those people you
could argue with decently and they're
pretty much gone so what i think bill is
missing there he's calling the radicals
a small element and the and the good
liberals he's saying they're the
majority i don't think so anymore and if
they are the majority if they're the
silent majority and they won't do jack
[ __ ] about it
then there's a problem now to that point
i again applaud bill for standing up
against this this is a fight worth
taking and for all these years
where i was say shifting or realizing
where there was fertile ground for ideas
and where i could make allies versus the
scourged earth i always said you could
find probably 50 videos of me saying if
my liberal friends prove me wrong if
they can actually save the democratic
party from this nonsense i will gladly
have a maya culpa absolutely i'll be
like boy i really missed the ball on
that one you guys sure were right you
really did stop the workstars but
there's no evidence of it so when they
when he talks about san francisco
crumbling or all these democratic places
crumbling the good liberals don't have
the wherewithal to stop it and what the
problem is so what that leads us to in
the final conclusion is unless
you are going to support glenn younkin
in virginia who's running against
critical race theory
and unless you are going to support ron
desantis who's keeping the state open
if you are going to not support the
people who are doing the whole freaking
thing but you're just going to
constantly say i'm still a liberal these
people are all idiots but somehow you
can't really vote for the people who are
doing the right thing because they're
racists or they believe in god or
they're morons or something
then there's a problem but i
will continue to try to have this
conversation because i think it's an
important one to have